magic killer clowns and the actual Grim
Reaper the ending of Twisted Metal
hinted at a lot of possibilities here's
what might be coming down the road in a
possible second season
John Doe is a Milkman essentially in
extremely skilled driver with a
souped-up and weaponized car who
couriers Goods such as medicine food and
other supplies across the
post-apocalyptic World Of The Divided
States of America John also has Amnesia
with only a burnt photo of him as a kid
to link him to his past it's eventually
revealed in episode 3 that the world
ended in the year 2002 after a Y2K type
event decimated everything all over the
world walled cities were constructed to
protect the affluent from the dangerous
outside world of Scavenging and violence
one such city is new San Francisco run
by the power hungry mayor Raven a place
John does Milkman runs for the story of
Twisted Metal gets going when Raven
offers Jon a job he can't pass up if you
go to new Chicago and bring this package
back from me I will make you a citizen
of new San Francisco I get to live here
John has 10 days to complete his mission
but things get complicated when he gets
carjacked by quiet she's a fugitive on
the run from agent Stone who leads a
dangerous gang of would-be police
officers while John and quiet are
antagonistic towards each other at first
they eventually learn to work together
and even fall in love over the course of
their violent road trip
at the end of Twisted Metal John Doe
completes Raven's Mission and delivers
the package from new Chicago to New San
Francisco at the last minute he's
looking forward to having a safe place
to live behind the city walls but his
new partner throws a wrench in the plan
quiet isn't allowed inside
we had a deal John
you and me and she's with me that's all
you need to know
before John has the chance to reject the
offer of Salvation in new San Francisco
to stay with quiet she shoots him the
violent Act is done out of love so Jon
can be taken into Medical Care by the
NSF Medics John is content in NSF for a
while but he becomes bored by the
repetitive routine of the suburban-like
existence of the Walden City when he
tells Raven his plans to leave NSF and
find quiet she tries to convince him to
stay by revealing his family was from
Old San Francisco before the apocalypse
Jon still insists on leaving but Raven
doesn't take the rejection well it's at
this point that she reveals her real
plan she sent John out to test his
driving before forcing him to represent
her in an upcoming contest
before quiet joined Jon on his mission
she had a quest of her own at the
beginning of the Season quiet's brother
loud kills himself rather than let his
sister die at the hands of agent Stone
the leader of a gang of cops trying to
restore order in the post-apocalyptic
divided States of America however rather
than restoring order they spread Terror
violence and fear including turning the
DMV into a Guantanamo bay-esque torture
black site though she helps Jon on his
Drive quiet never stops hunting for
stone and Jon's involvement complicates
things the loss of quiet's brother left
her hopeless end with a death wish but
John's friendship and later love make
her realize that she could find new
Connections In the End instead of
killing Stone In Cold Blood after
beating him in car combat she decides to
wash her hands of him and move on to
heal after she leaves Jon quiet going by
the code name roadkill becomes a
liberator of the Wasteland she steals
and hijacks supplies from Wayward
Milkmen to give back to the homeless and
needy in a Robin Hood sort of way
eventually though she's caught by the
doll face gang whose leader turns out to
be Jon's long-lost sister
while not one of the main characters Stu
is still important in the Twisted Metal
series he and his friend Mike are based
on the characters in Twisted Metal 2 who
drive the monster truck Hammerhead which
sadly doesn't make an appearance this
season in the show rather than being
metal headstoners who wish for the
ability to fly Mike and Stu are Wayward
scavengers about to be eaten by
cannibals before being saved by agent
Stone's goons Stone then offers Mike and
Stu the opportunity to be lawbringers
like them Stu however realizes very
quickly that he's not cruel enough to be
a lawbringer and Mike eventually sells
him out luckily before Stu is executed
he's rescued by Sweet Tooth the evil
clown takes a quick liking to Stew
partially due to them being big dudes
whose first names start with s
unfortunately while sweet tooth is
supportive of Stu he's also psychotic
and manipulative and at one point during
the final battle against Stone kills
some allies with no remorse there are no
sides Stuart everybody Burns
when Sweet Tooth forces Stu to kill Mike
Stu refuses standing up for himself and
shooting Sweet Tooth in the eye fans of
the game will recognize that this gives
the clown his iconic video game injury
from Twisted Metal black
like so much television and film these
days there is of course an after credit
scene following the ending of the
Twisted Metal finale we see Mike and Stu
enjoying their time together on a
secluded beach with their girlfriends
but they're interrupted by an unexpected
visitor
actually I have a better idea Mike and
Stu share a nervous laugh with Sweet
Tooth but they're terrified after all
the last time they saw the violent clown
they hit him with their van
unfortunately for them Sweet Tooth stops
laughing takes out a machete and stabs
Mike to death afterwards Sweet Tooth
drags stew away screaming is Mike
actually dead if so does it end the
potential of seeing Mike and Stu drive a
monster truck together well that could
indeed be true the whole thing could be
a fake out maybe Mike survives his
wounds or maybe it's the setup to an
elaborate joke it would definitely be
nice to see Mike return it would be a
pretty big disappointment to see
hammerhead on screen without both Mike
and stew behind the wheel
the Twisted Metal series isn't subtle
about its anti-capitalist nature it
shows the great disparity between the
Haves and have-nots in the new
post-apocalyptic society and how those
in power will always continue to amass
more wealth and Resources by exploiting
those in poverty this is made pretty
clear by the Walden cities of new San
Francisco or new Chicago in these cities
a small minority of affluent people live
in opulence and luxury while the
majority of the world lives in poverty
and squalor however the critique goes
beyond that consider quiet's backstory
set in the walled city of Orange County
after the end of the world the OC
becomes a fascistic nightmare where
white upper middle class and Suburban
coded denizens keep marginalized in
minority workers as slaves though not a
true reflection of the actual place
there is no question that our world has
a long and sad history of subjugating
citizens for the benefit of a few
wealthy and powerful people
another important message of Twisted
Metal is the necessity of human
connections bonds and community in
capitalism everything is set up as a
competition and relationships within
that system are meant to be seen as
transactional even personal friendships
under capitalism are often viewed as
merely stepping stones for people to
network and Elevate their careers always
at the expense of others we see how this
manifests at the beginning of the show
when John Doe's only friend is his car
Evelyn the same goes for quiet who
isolates herself from Human Connection
by not even speaking they both work
alone in their own little toxic Bubbles
and even when they're forced together
due to unforeseen circumstances they
still try to find ways to undermine or
exploit each other at every opportunity
once they decide to actually open up to
each other and work together as a team
they start to actually succeed in ways
they couldn't have if they were alone
they even find love and a bond that
their isolation denied them it's this
connection to others that even leads to
quite becoming a liberator for the
people of the Wasteland she is
attempting to Foster community by
providing them basic necessities denied
by their world
in an interview with sci-fi Samoa Joe
said he hopes that the second season
gets to be more violent and dark in the
first season of Twisted Metal sweet
tooth is far less bloodthirsty and evil
than he is in the games he is indeed
violent and psychotic but there's a
silliness to Joe and Will Arnett's
portrayal of the evil clown that's
absent from the games this is especially
true for the later games on which the
show is based in an interview with
deadline Anthony Mackey said John's
going to have some challenges that's
going to come his way that's gonna Force
his hand to be more of an adult and make
some really tough decisions because you
can't be a Milkman all your life it
seems that there are going to be many
morally gray moments in season two if it
indeed happens if twister quiet or even
his sister doll face joins the
tournament and its kill or be killed how
do you make the right choice of who
lives or dies one of the most exciting
aspects of the ending of Twisted Metal
season one is the fact that it actually
introduces the Twisted Metal contest
into the story much like the 2021 Mortal
Kombat movie the 2023 twisted metal
streaming series doesn't even introduce
the main event that the whole thing is
named after we'll just have to wait for
more episodes to continue the story to
hold over Die Hard fans there are
glimpses of other drivers from the game
including fan favorites Mr Grimm and
axel they also implied that other
drivers from the game who showed up
earlier in the series like twister
preacher and flower power will be
joining the Twisted Metal tournament as
well Raven is a playable character in
the 2001 game Twisted Metal black and
while the two characters have nothing in
common it's certainly possible that we
could see the show's version behind the
wheel finally there's also the
possibility that agent Stone survived
the finale after all we don't see him
die on screen could his character be
joining the tournament also we'll just
have to wait and see
another exciting thing about the end of
season 1 is that it could also lead to
the introduction of the supernatural
elements that exist in the game while
Jon and quiet here Calypso's voice while
picking up Raven's package in new
Chicago he's not really mentioned in the
show outside of some shots of graffiti
saying Calypso is real and such however
in the games Calypso is the one who runs
the Twisted Metal tournament in nearly
every entry and he has magical powers
that Grant any wish the winner of the
tournament desires though the wish
usually backfires in a monkey's paw sort
of way in the finale Once Raven forces
Jon at gunpoint to be her driver in the
Twisted Metal tournament she hints at a
big reward I need you to win because
Calypso is offering quite a prize the
winner gets their hearts desire the
greatest wish come true this might mean
that Calypso has magic powers in the
show as well this also means that Mr
Grimm who is briefly seen in one of the
photos during the Montage of contestants
could be the actual Grim Reaper like he
was in the first two games he's been
human in other games but the reaper
version is still a fan favorite
[Music]